では 一人一人が私たちは自分がかっこいいと思いますかと
まあこれはちょっと疑問なんですけど
自分がかっこいいと思う人もいるし
そうは思わない人もいるし
それはもう別にあまり気にすることではありません
まあだから自分がかっこいいと思う
思っても思わなくても
この守るべき言葉は二つあります
これが生命を管理するものが二つあります
自分も生命だから自分を管理してほしいんですね
デュエメビクエダンマスカローカンパーレンティカトメデュエヒリーとオッタッパンチ
これ長いんですから 文章は短くしたんです
二つの良い事柄がこの世を管理している
この二つの事柄とは 斬と義である
この二つがなければ 母も父も叔父もでしたっけ
もう兄弟も師匠なども成り立たなくなる
世界はヤギ 羊 犬 猫の間柄のようになると
人間というのは動物と同じくなるんだよと
私はもう時々怒鳴るでしょう
もう犬猫もより勝ってない
もうイカイカだよとか
でもお釈迦さんの言葉なんですからね
私は知りません  この二つの事柄がなくなっちゃうと
もう動物と同じなんです
このなぜ犬猫取ったかというと
犬が交尾するしたくなったら
相手が母親であろうと気にしないんです
猫もそうなんです 一緒に生まれた兄弟であろうと
交尾したいとか交尾する
何の道徳もない というわけで
人間にとってはとても必要な良い事柄二つあるんだ
それは斬と義というんですね
パーリ語でヒリーとオッタッとというんです
それだけ守ってみましょうと
自己制御ができること
最高にかっこいいと言えるのは
自己制御制御ができることです
これができる人はいかなる場合でも
誘惑に負けることなく
帝王のように生きられる
これも最高の格好いいと
自己制御できる 自分の管理できる
人に言われるまでは待ちません
人にあれこれやと言われるとカッコ悪いんですよ
人に何も言われなくても
しっかり自分の管理できれば
まあすごいかっこいいんです
一は前の教典にあったんですから
ヒリですね ヒリっていうのは悪を恥じるということなんです
2番目はオッタッパというんですね
意味は悪を怖がる それで我々一人一人が恥と怖がる二つだけ守れば
もうかっこいいってことなんです
ですから 恥といったっても
まあ良い恥と言わなくちゃいけないんです
どんな恥もいいわけじゃないんです
良い恥 一切の悪行為 社会が非難する行為
両親が悩む行為 人間としてのプライドを傷つく行為などを犯すことは
この上のない恥だと思うことです
これが恥なんです 悪いことならものすごく恥ずかしいと
もう気持ち悪くなるほど恥ずかしくなった方がいいんです
高いプライドを持って
芯の強い人間として生きることですね
だからそんな恥ずかしい
そんなことやりませんよと
気持ち悪いでしょうと
だからあなた ちょっとこれ嘘言ったらいいでしょと
やりませんよと 気持ち悪いんだ
いくらなんでもとか あんた
あの人怒鳴っちゃえばいいんじゃないか
人怒鳴ることは気持ち悪い
恥ずかしいんだ 一度も怒鳴ったことはないんだよと言ってプライドを持つんですよ
だから恥じるということは
すごいプライドあるということなんです
だから結局仏教ではもう高いプライドを持ちなさいと言っているんです
これ どんなプライドかというと
悪を恥じるプライドなんです
でないでしょ だから母親を殺して首まで持っていくんだから
首を持ってゲームセンターのどこかでインターネットカフェでもう遊んでいるという
どういう人間かと たとえ脅されても誘惑されても
プライドを守る 自分の生き方を曲げないことです
脅してもあなたこれやらなくちゃ
あなたこの何て言いますか
警棒 掛け警棒というんですか
会計のをね それちょこちょことごまかしてくれなきゃ
もうもうクビにするぞと言っても
悪いことはやらんと しっかり芯の強い生き方なんです
悪いことはならやりませんと
はい もうすぐ終わると思います
世間の無意味な悪になるプライドと違います
世間のプライドっていうのは悪そのものなんですよ
いろんな私は国会議員だとか
私は何々人だとかね えらいプライド
傲慢で あれは悪ですよ
私は悪いことをしないのだというプライドが正しいんです
いくらなんでもやりませんよと
金がいくらくれたってもやりませんと
そのプライド それがなくなっちゃうと
みんな悪いことをしちゃうんです
それから良い臆病 まあ臆病はちょっと一切の悪を犯すことに対して臆病になるんです
もう怖い 怖い ダメダメ
臆病とは言い過ぎかもしれませんが
悪いことをしようとすると震えて体が動かない状態になるならば
正真正銘の善人です 悪いことをしようとすると
なんか体が怖くて硬直しちゃって
もう腰が動かなくなっちゃうんだと
それだったら正真正銘の良い人間なんです
もう怖くて怯えてもう体止まっちゃうんです
大体怖くなっちゃうとみんな硬直しちゃうでしょ
この場合は 悪いことをするときは体が止まるという
良いことなら何でもやる性格こそが勇気なのです
同じ人が良いことだったらもう何でもやる
すぐ動く体が 悪いことになってくると
もう怯えて怖くなっちゃって
体が動かなくなっちゃう
喋れなくなっちゃう 良いことだったらペラペラ喋りますけど
なんか悪いこと喋ろうと思っちゃうと
もうもう黙ってしまって
もう喋れなくなっちゃうと
いうことなんです これで生命一かっこいい人間になるんです
私はわざと生命一と書いたんです
なぜならば 皆様知ってるのは世界一ということだからね
もっとかっこいいんです
世界一のところじゃなくて
生命一なんです だから初めも言いましたから
神々さえも神々にさえも褒められる生き方をしなくちゃかっこ悪いんですよ
仏教では 神に賛嘆したり
神に賛美歌を歌ったりとか
情けないと思いますよ
だから有名な誰かさんが書いたアヴェマリアを歌ってるんだよとかね
えらいかっこ悪いと思います
私はすごいかっこ悪いと思いますよ
アヴェマリアって曲自体がものすごく歌いにくいからくりだからね
それは歌える人の方がまあなかなかの俺
褒めますけど だからといって
それ本当にあの神に歌うならばね
惨めなんですよ だから
それよりは逆に神に褒められる人間にならなくちゃいけない
それは仏教がいうかっこいい良さなんです
ですから 世界一かっこいいんじゃなくて
仏教を目指すのは生命一かっこよささなんです
生ゴミは自慢の種ではない
それは説明してないんですけど
我々は自慢にするのは生ゴミなんですね
もう体重はこれぐらいとか
ヒップはこれぐらいとか
胸はこれぐらいとか 生ゴミ
お金がこれぐらいあるとか
フランスで自分のアパートありますよとか
オーストラリアでも家一軒持ってますよとか
テレビでよく誰かさんが来てよくそういう自慢しますけどね
まあ飛行機を持ってるんだとかね
そんなのは生ゴミで 今全部生ゴミだから
財産 健康 美しさ 権力 名誉
人気などは自分のものにならないんですからね
そういうものは生ゴミだと思ってください
自分はそれ全て捨てて死ななくてはならないんですからね
結局は 生ゴミっていうのは捨てるもんでしょ
あったとしても 自分はそれらの奴隷になるんです
そんなのは 奴隷生活はかっこ悪いんです
もう明らかに 自分と一体になる道徳
知恵 人格などを身につくことが期待するべき
憧れるべき生き方です
だから生ゴミ拾って俺が偉いそうではなくて
自分と一体になるもの
取った方がいいんです
いわゆる自分自身を向上することですね
そうなってくると 道徳
嘘を言わないことは自分と一体だからね
真理を語ることは自分と一体だから
誰かに持っていくことはできません
それから知恵 知恵も自分と一体ですね
人格も自分自身だからね
そういうものは育てるんですね
それが期待して頑張ってほしいと
それからそれに憧れるべきですと
これで終わりと思います
かっこよさは本当は正確よさです
かっこよさっていうのは正確よさなんです
仏教から見ると これは相続するものではなく
自分の力で育ち上げるものです
で 世間でいうね すごいかっこいい人がいるんだけど
その人は生まれつき母親からもらった体だからね
相続していますよ だから他の人には共通じゃないんです
本当のかっこよさが相続するものじゃないんです
自分で新たに育てるんです
というわけで どんな人間にも生命一かっこよい人間になれます
心が美しい人は何をやっても美しいんです
太陽のごとく 他の生命の役に立つ人間になってしまうんです
心が美しいんだったら
一人一人が太陽のごとく
世の中に光を与える人間になるんです
また 誰にでもできることです
ポイントは これは誰にでもできますと
まあ一応そんな程度だと思います
話は そういうわけで かっこいい人間になるようにと頑張ってみてください
話は終了です  時間過ぎておりますが
ご質問等ありましたら